welcome to this video playing Grand
Master dammit Enoch even Shah Rukh OS a
very strong player so 1g3 normally is a
efore and e4 guys so it's a bit without
comment by my guest and so is this an
idea okay can maybe take you five let's
try that anyway so we get some kind of
reverse to grow and free okay I don't
want that Queenie a teenage five I have
this autopilot attack that are
definitely that I'm going definitely
going to try k & ago still go here I am
okay mm f4 anyway yeah I think it
shouldn't be bad opening up the bishop
a ship is Judith Bishop g4 I thought
that was a substantial threat but he did
not really do anything I can hear the
check okay okay yeah let's take quindi
fat check maybe huh interesting and then
he will probably play the night I can
take a tool but I have my doubts I
doesn't look right take a tool so I'm
going to take here first it's called
book a one at the end this is why I have
my doubts about Luca Luca hmmm cat III
maybe just this that part is very very
annoying and I have some activity here
my pieces are rather active so it might
be okay we didn't thought rook see one
may be coming but so I should probably
move this rope so that i have c 5
available okay look the eight fish over
here I guess check check ah yes sure you
can bundle the rook in this dead
position I'm stupid okay black resent us
and very stupid yeah it was just
absolutely nothing going on the whole
time I shoot i simply i just blundered
this yeah i can play whatever king of
seven or so i don't think that's much
going on here maybe this look f5 was was
unnecessarily fancy I mean this is may
be easier to have the rook somewhere
here to defend and c5 it's just equal
yeah but okay if you if you blunder
blunder into mates it in turn yeah you
deserve to lose a single king of 7am
check very stupid that still is okay
engine is on 0.3 or so ah what is stupid
blunder okay
then I want to look at one thing in the
opening okay it's it's not super
relevant theoretically but I wondered if
Knight takes d5 is good yeah that's the
best move she didn't think about it all
yeah i was wandering that looked like a
pretty good version of that of that that
that motif something like this is
certainly bit better for wild yeah he
didn't think about it at all okay thanks
for watching